[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler
show i'm your host paul aka he who
spoils
and in this video we're breaking down
every can clue in loki season 1.
episode 6 revealed that the man behind
the curtain was actually a variant of
nathaniel richards
who we know has taken on many identities
and aliases
renowned throughout the marvel universe
as kang the conqueror he's traveled
through many timelines attempting to
take over all
and the first season did lay the
groundwork with a lot of easter eggs and
call backs to the comics to let us know
he was coming
we're going to be breaking them all down
in this video and if you enjoy it then
please smash the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe if you're
a marvel maniac as we're going to be
doing weekly breakdowns on what if
and of course the trailer for spider-man
no way home now in general i think the
biggest clue was the tva itself
as well as the timekeepers often linked
to kang he used to work for them
until he ended up going off to do his
own thing against their wishes
the fact that the timekeepers were there
but that there was no sign of kang
coupled with the reveal that they were
robots was a big indicator that one of
his variants was behind it all
i did say this all the way back in
episode one and yeah i know i made like
700 different fan theories but we got it
right
first time first first try got it right
exactly right first try now we also know
from the comics that he
remains create the timekeepers and i
really appreciate that they took these
characters and pushed them together to
give a soft introduction to who's coming
down the line
in the final episode he he remains also
refers to himself as the devil
and though he's not necessarily god the
fact that the central time keeper looked
a lot like jonathan mages
did hint at things slightly god created
man in his image
and it makes sense that the time keepers
would be created in their master's image
as for now they're some of the
characters greatest creations
the resemblance to kang amongst the
timekeepers was so uncanny
that when we got a look at their heads
in the first trailer people
genuinely thought it was the conqueror's
face due to the lines and shape of it
in addition to this was ravonna
renslayer a loving trust of kang who
could often be seen in front of this
central figure
now not only was he a key statue in her
office but when she was carrying out
loki's trial his face
also towered over hers almost
encompassing the character
when we're first introduced to her she
appears in front of his lips
perhaps symbolizing that she is very
much the voice of kang
carrying out his commands unbeknownst to
her for a long time
she was the only one allowed to speak to
the timekeepers who of course were
controlled by kang
unless it makes sense that she appears
like this throughout the entire series
this certainly lets us know that he was
controlling her and everything in the
tva
and it makes sense as to why she doesn't
wish to break free of the tva
even upon learning the truth in the
finale in the comics ren slayer was a
princess from the 43rd century
that fell in love with kang and for a
long time she ruled chronopolis which is
the kingdom that belonged to him
inside this was some of the seven
wonders of the world including the
pyramids
which popped up in the void hinting to
us that it was
now in the comics kang also used a time
machine disguised as the sphinx
and this had its nose intact unlike the
one in our real world
the nose could also be seen as being
present on the one in the void
further linking it all to kang now the
season ended with a statue dedicated to
kang in an alternate version of the tva
and though we don't know where ravona
went
i do believe that she will have traveled
to this universe after learning of it
from his minutes
you pretty much don't get here the tva
and the timekeepers without kang
so looking back it just made a lot of
sense knowing what we do from the source
material
the credits also contained a subtle clue
and we could see a coffee pot which
contained a sticker on it that said
fresh 800 bc
800 bc was actually the year that kang
traveled back in time to
when he changed his identity to rama tut
due to his highly advanced technology
he was able to rule over all in ancient
egypt until became a pharaoh and
challenged for many decades
this further ties back to his love of
pyramids which of course popped up in
the void
and also his home now after loki escaped
in the events of avengers end game
he traveled to the gobi desert where he
was discovered by a tribe
this is going to be the biggest reach in
the video i i promise that
however you will probably know that the
desert is located in northern china
and southern mongolia the name kang
actually comes from the kangju tribe
who moved into china from central asia
during the reign of the han dynasty
now i said it might be a rich richards
but this location being where we start
does hint towards where we finish now
there was also a device that the tva
used called the time twisters
and in the comics these were actually
beings who were created by he who
remains
whilst trying to make the timekeepers
they were twisted villainous versions
but looks like their name was carried
across to this show to hint
at he who was behind it all now episode
5
was completely filled with nods towards
kang we start off with a one shot that
went from the tva
to the head of the central timekeeper
before moving through the void to bring
focus to the king building
king was actually a company owned by an
alternate version of kang
and he ended up buying avengers tower
from tony stark in order to use it as
his base of operations
it's here that we also got eliath a
trans-dimensional cloud that roamed the
void consuming everything it could
clouds have often appeared in comic book
movies but they've always been terrible
however i'm glad they managed to
actually make a good one and you know
what i quite like goliath
now in the comics elithe was a
malevolent force that was
accidentally freed by ravonna renslayer
and kang ended up capturing it and using
it as a pet
this is of course carried across to the
show and even nathaniel's backstory
though the bit about ravona is
completely missing
it was also around this time that
jonathan mages was doing press
interviews
and when asked by variety if he was in
loki he said i don't know what you're
talking about
however variety sounds like variant
and also yeah a bit of a reach that but
he did shut the interview down
suspiciously fast
like very very fast faster than i upload
breakdowns which is very
very suspicious now finally the last big
clue towards kang
came when we watched loki and sylvie
open up goliath
kang's colors have always been green
purple and blue which could all be seen
within the cloud as it opened up
now we could see that he who remains was
also wearing clothing that's typically
associated with a mortise
and this makes me think that he's
actually more in line with that older
version of kang
he of course has outlived all the other
versions in the past to create this one
timeline that will avoid war
and thus we can take it that he's one in
the same and that the variants we'll be
experiencing from here on out
are younger versions of him now one big
question that's been itching away at me
is who was controlling he who remains
the character was given a script of how
everything would play out
but beyond this he didn't know the way
that things would go and thus we can
take it that he wasn't the one who wrote
it
i actually think that a loki variant
will be the ruler who gave him this
knowledge
and it may even potentially be sylvie as
she decides to take over his position in
the end
she experienced this conversation
firsthand and would have the script
thus her going forward would enable her
to give this to he who remains in the
past
so that he could carry out these events
exactly the way that she told him
it's very much the bootstrap paradox and
if we look at the comic agent of asgard
it was revealed that an older loki was
behind that all and therefore it just
makes the most sense to me
anyway i'm kind of going off course now
but i will be doing a further video on
this discussing where i think the show
could be going next
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
and if there's any clues we missed
i think i got them all but the show is
almost 6 hours long
so i'm sure there's something there that
i'd love to read in the comments
drop them below and just to let you know
we're running a competition right now
and giving away three mcu box sets on
the 30th of july
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of every month and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now
so message me at heavyspoilers on
twitter if that's you if you want emails
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of episode 6 which
will be linked on screen right now we've
gone over the entire thing from top to
bottom
and pointed out all the symbolism and
easter eggs in it so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more without the way thank you missing
through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care
peace